lot of people don't have confidence in  Xbox or any of their releases me and  Cognito talked about this repeatedly I  love the fact that Kings out here being  like screw it launch it the day of  freaking Zelda perhaps the biggest game  next this upcoming year right so I love  that confidence the king I think you're  fighting the wrong battle here because  you know what would be a  be a 20 second same day as Final Fantasy  16 give the middle finger to squaring  yeah Starfield star film quality Final  Fantasy 16. and you send a message to  square as well like you're not gonna put  your games on our platform and you're  just gonna take songs  [Music]  right you can have your you see you  squarely can Target a a better franchise  that's been doing things you can  squarely Target it see what you just  told me is you think Final Fantasy is an  easy duck